we turn on
why is it goes why can't you just turn
up the TV so that's weird apparently
because of the way it's hooked up it
only okay I have a turn the brightness
up so I can see what the hell is going
on crap multipliers single-player and
shun action bloodshot a high club it's
where you fight Tyler Tyler Tom Thomas
you can he's enderton take Laxman Ethan
Morse shout out to that nerd oh that's
right that needs to be a fighting
underneath nah man gene just run around
fighting people wrestling rings hahaha
Mike he's at the very top but at the
last match before he gets he beats the
chin went to gym chick he suddenly has
another breakdown he just falls out of
the bottom realizes that he needs to
stop doing cocaine he needs to stop
doing cocaine and stuck good for him
then then he meets a single mom and they
fall in love and through that power I
you know what John you know what there
is a Jean Claude Van Damme movie that is
exactly like what you're describing 1 2
3 well go normal sir playing spongebob
the video game yes a rock bottom you
know it's bikini bottom no rock pop
although that one episode there was one
episode ever move that go I would have
killed you what's up with that radio any
idea who this man why are you call that
guy is Grandpa Max and Ben 10 seems like
it you've you listen to voices told him
it looks like him too haha let's just
cuz he looks like an old guy he's just a
generic was good
charges you're probably still milking
that show actually it's still on really
yep are they making new seasons they're
bad or they yeah okay it had it was it
was an awesome like fun kids show but as
the audience got older they did the
sequel that was like teenage based and
it was all dark and gritty and cool and
now they're doing the third series which
goes back to being childish carbonia and
that's when I stopped watching okay so
make sure to talk over the music because
we'll get in trouble of YouTube's
copyright laws because they really don't
like when you have music in your videos
that you're not talking over so I have
to make sure to talk about uh just keep
comment on this guy's drinking problem
okay also ok that's a creepy-looking
hobo man we're gonna go over and punch
his face into his face okay now we're
gonna get kicked out of the bar for
murdering you got right then and now the
economy is rough on a homeless minimal
oh no the phone is ringing oh look it's
a wise homeless man yeah but bow uh yeah
that's a lot of cutscenes isn't it it's
like Metal Gear it's no it's not my time
we're here is Ben not nearly that
there's nothing boo subtitles sit still
you're like my cousin shout out to my
cousin you know who you are why can't I
punch you in your face all tutorials
top middle gear could literally be a
movie if you wanted that's all so i can
do sick kicks yeah wha here's a fourth
meal here is like our how many does have
game plans for you yeah my way nervous
why are we knew why are we friends I'm a
dick okay so the first one is where
you're a police officer who loses things
who's Hispanic for some reason and looks
or black almost it looks nothing like
this guy but is apparently the same
character and uh what are you doing okay
it's that guy killed in the bar so we
play a tough homeless man who beats up
other homeless men alright sounds mate
yeah let's go see Adams easy fix good
I'll punch it sure go ahead what's up
I'll put you to curb stomp curb stomp
curb stomping intensifies [ __ ] you
Elmore 20 good kick how I can dig I
don't play dark souls apparently it's
the only video game that Jackson likes
yes the only one of all of them okay I
wish that I know how to do the combat
game and I turn off the tutorial I'm
beating the crap out of this guy out
all right come on let's do this yeah
because they're crazy homeless men
because they're possessed by the devil
that's there yes that is the plot that
is the mess that's the Madonna my level
Telltale Games don't have anything on it
oh yeah I got a I got this stick with
nails in it look out he's gonna forward
with a nail in it yeah honey I'm being
killed by cutscene powers no this is
such a year it's such a weird game
because we're missing context because we
didn't play the first one also we're
going and say now everything's a word a
ghost city now ghost city yea big null
says to go towards the light swords oh
sweet grab the antenna and watch TV was
as if though this were the 90s do you
remember doing this Jackson no that's
because we were born like five hours ago
babies
oh no all we just got vomited all over
right now hi you look stupid I sit next
to my pc and its really light something
is moving toward oh no they touch it's
gated check this out this Skinner bird
I'm so happy he puts Britain my I'm so
happy this is my wallet he grabs my
wallet with his powerful hand I'm ready
oh no often live wallet for game he
starts taking the money her tied to it
Kate I give it here like I don't scare
that I lists is flying leg I tried to
resist the urge I want to please gated
here orders of mighty where are these
bills my library straight in the eyes
and says come join us Wow game is Jim
Sutherland uh-oh marble where's that
pipe I hand it's like the coolest weapon
others yeah but yeah monkey stop his ass
oh oh the thing is it that's nothing
well you wanna fight too yeah whatever